[Música]
en primera plana
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio francia internacional 10
france24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
la cuestión de la salud democrática en
américa latina' nos preguntamos está la
democracia tradicional en crisis en la
región vemos como en numerosos países el
último de ellos chile los partidos
tradicionales han quedado noqueados en
los procesos electorales y así una larga
lista lo vamos a ver con los siguientes
invitados patrick weil periodista del
diario le figaro que cubre la rúbrica
américa latina' bienvenido patrick
wilson david gormezano periodista en
france 24 es fue ex corresponsal en
brasil en argentina david bienvenido
hola carlos y en dúplex desde chile ya
es una musa corresponsable recibió en
venida hayas na
buenos días en parís saludo desde
santiago de chile- muchas gracias por
escrito siempre la crisis política
tradicional en américa latina hoy en
primera plana
[Música]
en chile los partidos tradicionales se
quedaron fuera del balotaje en las
elecciones que el izquierdista boris
ganó al ultraderechista cast otro
ultraderechista bolsonaro también
eclipsó las formaciones tradicionales en
brasil en perú se repite esta misma
dinámica un panorama que comienza a
repetirse en varios países de la región
a veces con populistas y otras con
personalismos que algunos califican de
autoritarios especialmente los casos de
américa central hoy nos planteamos si
existe una crisis respecto a los
partidos tradicionales y si los
personalismos han empezado a ocupar una
posición preponderante en el panorama de
américa latina' y buscamos las causas de
este fenómeno repasemos antes algunas
portadas diario 'el mercurio' gabriel
boric presenta su nuevo gabinete
poniendo foco en restaurar la confianza
enfrentar la pandemia y restaurar la
economía aquí en francia el diario le
monde ha dedicado un amplio artículo
titulado la crecida de la extrema
derecha en distintos países de américa
latina refleja un crecimiento de
tensiones por el ejemplo de chile perú
argentina donde movimientos
ultraconservadores
encuentran un eco en la sociedad
estoy editorializa con el titular la
plaga bolsonaro merece ser extirpada de
brasil de cara a las elecciones de
octubre y la revista foreign affairs
titula los dilemas de américa latina'
vamos a hablar de esos dilemas políticos
de la región para lo primero patrick
podemos hablar de que hay una crisis de
la política tradicional en favor de
outsiders y populistas que quizás sepan
interpretar mejor en estos momentos a la
opinión pública en américa latina' lo
que me parece es que estamos saliendo de
una crisis económica que puede
dificultar los los políticos
tradicionales sí claro pero hay otra
cosa es que la derecha hay una realmente
una nueva izquierda que vemos por
ejemplo en colombia o en honduras esta
semana castro
el poder
en china y también es una izquierda
nueva y se salieron de la izquierda de
los años 90 y la derecha no hay
nuevas personas así se da un lugar a los
extrema derecha también en brasil en
chile
pero es la falta de personalidad de
falta de una derecha que la derecha es
solamente hacen referencia al pasado en
80 en un discurso del futuro y me parece
que es eso que es el problema que vemos
en alicante medios tenemos una crisis de
la derecha que no se ha renovado y que
ha dejado espacio a la extrema derecha y
por otro lado una nueva izquierda que a
lo mejor se ha distanciado un poco de lo
que era venezuela
la crítica habitual que se le decía a
una cierta izquierda latinoamericana no
sé si david coincide con este
diagnóstico sí claro creo que tenemos
una izquierda al momento en
latinoamérica que está más moderada que
radical
salvo cuba venezuela y nicaragua que son
ejemplos además muy puntuales
en chile
se está preparando un gabinete muy
moderado con un ministro de hacienda que
viene del partido socialista que fue
nombrado por la presidenta michelle
bachelet confirmado por el presidente
conservador de sebastián piñera
no no no veo en el gobierno que vienen
en chile común un gobierno de la
izquierda radical para nada y veamos
también en colombia por ejemplo gustavo
petro que está muy alto en las encuestas
para las elecciones de mayo que que está
haciendo que está buscando alianzas por
el
lado de la derecha hay unos políticos de
que vienen del uribismo que parecen
apoyar a su candidatura él está buscando
una base electoral más amplia que la
izquierda que nunca ganó en colombia así
que que no ahora ve de una una derecha
que se radicaliza en américa latina y
una izquierda que tal vez es más
moderada que en algunos otros momentos
históricos del continente hablando de
exilio vamos a en este punto a preguntar
a nuestra corresponsal ya es una musa
porque los partidos tradicionales se
quedaron fuera del balotaje en las
últimas elecciones chilenas ya es nada
donde hay que buscar las causas y que se
dicen chile de esta crisis de las
formaciones clásicas
los partidos mostraron muy desconectados
de la realidad social demostrar muy
desconectados de
lo que vivían los ciudadanos y
ciudadanas de manera cotidiana por lo
que se fue notando este nivel de
desconexión y la falta de
digamos de una interpretación de las
necesidades de la gente por lo que yo
creo que obviamente punto máximo ahí fue
el estallido social la revuelta de 2019
en el que la gente comenzó a no sólo
exigir que hubiera un cambio a nivel de
políticas públicas sino que también un
cambio en sus representantes ya no
sentían que sus representantes estaban
llevando sus necesidades a buen puerto y
esto la verdad se profundizó muchísimo
más con esta revuelta que luego bueno si
bien el punto máximo fue quizá en
octubre de 2019 siguió extendiéndose y
hasta el día de hoy vemos que hay una
disconformidad de parte de la población
con lo que han sido los últimos 30 años
de gobiernos por dictaduras
precisamente hablando de el otro que
llegó al balotaje en chile josé antonio
kast el ultraderechista veíamos antes
son las portadas que el diario alemán
ponía el foco en estos momentos ultra
conservadores y de ultraderecha que
comienzan a tener eco no solo en brasil
perú chile argentina podemos hablar de
una nueva ultraderecha en latinoamerica
patrick no me parece una
ultraderecha nueva es una lucha derecha
que hace referencia siempre al pasado a
la nostalgia de un momento pasado en el
american al directamente cast hizo la
diferencia alpino -seis- victimismo
en brasil pero la diferencia
el momento
en perú siempre es una referencia del
pasado
no me parece que la nueva ultraderecha
es un resurgimiento de la cultura
derecha pero a ver hay solamente en
brasil donde ganó este ultraderecha en
los otros países quizás es fuerte pero
nunca gana como la medida dicen que se
podría aparecer y diferenciar de las
ultraderechas europeas estos movimientos
de ultraderecha de américa latina me
parece claro que la victoria de trump en
eeuu en el 2016 dio mucha fuerza a
corrientes de la derecha tradicional
o de la ultraderecha
nostálgica de la época de las dictaduras
militares en latinoamérica
en la compañía en chile ojos ante
educaste quería y su compañía para hacer
un burro a la frontera norte para
impedir la llegada de inmigrantes
haitianos
venezolanos
eso parece muy la comparación a
comparación con un control de esta
evidente
y es muy diferente de la extrema derecha
europea me parece la ultraderecha en
europa está obsesionada con el fenómeno
de los migrantes
y están cesada con los musulmanes y el
el islam y el mundo islámico eso en la
américa latina me parece
no no es un tema grave
posicionarse a la inmigración
inmigración legal y legal es el nuevo en
américa latina porque el américa
fenómenos de inmigración o las de
inmigrantes es la historia del
continente y ahora ese discurso como el
de josé antonio kast
me parece bastante nuevo sí pero parece
que sí que hay dos temas o dos ejes que
definen bastante a esa ultraderecha uno
es agitar el ejemplo de venezuela del
comunismo y sobre todo del lo anti lg y
el anti feminismo es eso que tiene en
contra de la llamada política de género
que en una región a veces se encuentra
con países muy conservadores
lo que está pasando en eeuu el
crecimiento de la derecha
evangélica
ultraconservadora me parece que tiene
una influencia muy importante en algunos
sectores
de en latinoamérica y que de alguna
manera un escritor argentino hizo un
libro que se llama la rebeldía se volvió
de derecha y si me parece que en brasil
en argentina en chile hay una parte de
la juventud que que quiere los estos
temas que están tan fuertes en eeuu
vamos en este punto a chile con nuestra
corresponsal ya es una musa ya están a
pie de calle qué imagen tienen los
ciudadanos de estas formaciones
tradicionales con que las vinculan y por
qué se desmarcan ahora de ellas esta
narrativa que utilizan los partidos
tradicionales que ya no se condice con
las necesidad actuales
no ha sabido interpretar y representar
ciertas necesidades y también cierto
cansancio después de tantos años de
una dictadura entre la ex concertación y
la nueva mayoría que paran los los
partidos tradicionales que gobernaron
hasta hace poco
quienes además de esta desconexión
también
y demostraron que no eran muy diferente
de lo que criticaban a nivel transversal
hubo casos bastante notables de
corrupción y estos casos de corrupción
fueron generando en la población no sólo
una visión crítica sino que también en
una falta de credibilidad bastante
profunda y eso se vio reflejado en las
últimas elecciones del año pasado 2021
es un año en el que tuvimos de manera
excepcional muchísimos procesos
de elecciones durante todo el año y en
cada uno de estos procesos se notó cómo
la población tomaba la distancia de la
política más tradicional y se atrevía a
apostar por proyectos nuevos y por otras
narrativas que estaban mucho más
actualizadas muchas gracias ya es nada
desde chilenos queda un montón de temas
que analizar sobre esta crisis de los
partidos tradicionales en américa
latina' lo vamos a hacer a vuelta de una
breve pausa aquí en radio francia
internacional y france 24 hasta ahora
todas las semanas tenemos una cita para
hablar de mujeres en ellos hoy hablamos
de nuestra diversidad nuestros logros y
nuestras luchas constantes aquí
entrevistamos a las que generan el
cambio en el mundo y les contamos sus
historias
[Música]
el día soy en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]
porque la historia se escribe el día a
día
porque la actualidad no espera la
información dondequiera que esté en
cualquier circunstancia
todos los temas para entender el mundo
para imaginar el mundo
france24 una mirada diferente liberté
égalité actually ti
seguimos aquí en primera plana esta
semana hablando de la crisis de los
partidos tradicionales en américa
latina' planteándonos porque emergen
tantas figuras outsider o de extrema
derecha o si hay una nueva izquierda en
analizando el panorama en general
político de tendencias que se está
produciendo en la región lo hacemos con
patrick weil del diario le figaro con
david corneta no periodista en france24
y con nuestra corresponsal en santiago
ya es na mussap hemos hablado de la
ultraderecha lo hablábamos antes de la
pausa de las derivas ultraconservadoras
pero hablemos ahora de figuras
autoritarias hay una creciente demanda
en estos momentos de incertidumbre sobre
todo además a partir de esta pandemia
que hemos vivido de figuras autoritarias
de figuras que tengan un peso patrick en
la región
hablaré de la región en general me
parece un poquito equivocábamos porque
sí sí
el situación de chile por ejemplo es muy
diferente y la situación de colombia y
si hay si hay cambios políticos no son
los mismos
[Música]
no hay que hacer comparación que no
saben si hay cambios
si hablamos de colombia por ejemplo
porque este espectro puede ganar es
siempre simplemente por que violente
años decirse soy de izquierda soy con
las farc y ahora que
desaparecen se puede decir estoy soy de
izquierda como petro e imaginar ganar la
elección presidencial es una historia
totalmente diferente en chile porque
bolivia no encontraron ultraderecha y si
hay si hay una crisis que necesita
que quiera ganar de personaje muy fuerte
hay que hablar que no gano si estaba
calificado por segundo vuelta contra
decirlo el único de la lista que ya no
es bolsonaro y finalmente con poder y
que no están tan extremista solamente en
el discurso efectivamente no podemos
homogeneizar a toda la región porque es
muy amplia tiende a realidades muy
distintas pero sí quizá podemos ver
algunas tendencias usted patrick
apuntado a una antes que sí que se puede
ver más o menos en toda la región que es
una crisis de la derecha clásica en
favor de la extrema derecha es eso sí
que lo estamos pudiendo detectar en
muchos países
en honduras y donde
la casa política tradicional del río
esta vez de nuevo con amor
para castró la esposa de zelaya
realmente es son situaciones muy
diferentes en cada uno de los países
como lo ve david hace muchos años que
américa latina se polariza políticamente
muchísimo y de un lado si hay
esta atracción por por hombres de que
vienen de una derecha que tiene una
personalidad autoritaria
del otro lado
y derechos para para las mujeres
figuras
políticas que son mujeres que son
progresistas también tienen éxito en
latinoamérica
así que
es este fenómeno de polarización que
estamos viendo desde hace 15 años que me
parece ser se fortalece que no de un
lado hay atracción por candidatos muy
autoritarios y de otro lado hay
todo el ámbito de los derechos de gmt
del feminismo y está creciendo también
está creciendo y que a veces se defiende
incluso que de una forma más insistente
que en países europeos es decir que esa
es otra realidad también existe en
américa latina y como hay algunas leyes
que se han aprobado en países como
argentina que ni siquiera se han
aprobado en países europeos vamos en
este punto a chile con nuestra
corresponsal ya es una musa para
preguntarle se hable en la prensa
chilena de una crisis de la democracia
tradicional como hasta ahora le hemos
conocido ya es no creo que
más bien con la última elecciones sobre
todo en el balotaje la democracia se vio
reforzada porque el chile nunca hasta
ahora había tenido tanta participación y
más veces superior 8,3 millones de
personas y gabriel boric se transformó
con 4,6 millones de votos en el
presidente más votado
y eso habla de que sí bien
hemos vivido momentos de mucha tensión
el mismo día del balotaje el candidato
de la extrema derecha antonio kast dijo
que si era poca la diferencia él no iba
a reconocer el triunfo de su
contrincante y quizás esa esposa ese
tono pensaron la situación pusieron un
poco tan valieron digamos la estabilidad
democrática con la que contamos los
últimos años pero sin embargo luego
salió reforzado y se vieron cosas
bastante simbólicas que son hablan la
mente de la tradición republicana del
país de por ejemplo que cuando ya se
confirmó que bolivia había ganado el
propio caso salió a reconocer el triunfo
de su contrincante lo llamó para
felicitarlo se ha logrado convocar de
manera sorpresiva como la última
elección a parte de una población que no
se sentía convocada antes que por los
jóvenes por ejemplo que fueron bastante
crítico y en otra oportunidad llevaron
incluso a boicotear las elecciones y
ahora se sumaron y también a las mujeres
por ejemplo que se vieron muy convocadas
de acuerdo
lo que reflejan los estudios digamos de
quienes votaron en las últimas
elecciones de diciembre pasado
hay analistas que apuntan como clave
fundamental estructural de este fenómeno
que hoy analizamos la búsqueda de
offside verso de hombres y mujeres
autoritarios desvincularse de partidos
tradicionales
lo apuntan a un fenómeno en concreto que
es la frustración de las clases medias
de latinoamérica tuvieron un ascenso y
ante la recesión económica la
frustración el descontento al
comprobarse que no se pueden
materializar ciertos anhelos que tenían
además ahora impulsados todavía más con
la pandemia coinciden con este
diagnóstico de una frustración de cierta
clase media en américa latina' que no ha
llegado a ser como en europa
es cierto que era la situación económica
en latinoamérica de los últimos cinco o
seis años no está buena
hubo un momento en los años 2000 con con
el boom de los
el boom económico y ahora estamos en un
ciclo de recesión y eso pueden poner los
partidos tradicionales bajo tensión
porque muchos han han fracasado en
mejorar la situación económica
estábamos hablando de politización y ahí
hay miedo al miedo de las clases de la
clase media de perder su nivel de vida y
los privilegios
que pienso que eso particularmente en
brasil fue clave en la elección de
personas
patrick coincide en esta frustración de
la clase media que se ha podido producir
después del boom económico que vivió
totalmente en las manifestaciones y en
chile en 2019 y en colombia también hay
manifestaciones en 2019 y que las
manifestaciones regresaron este este
junio de columbia
y vemos en colombia la población de
jóvenes que estaban prestando muy a
veces con violencia y la clase media
estaba al lado de estos jóvenes diciendo
que no realmente la situación es muy
mala y la pandemia
e hizo crecer este sentimiento de
crisis por la casa media
creen que es parcialmente sensible a la
situación de algún país en este ámbito
de desapego a las instituciones
democráticas que esto se ha visto
especialmente en algún país de la región
ese desapego de la de las instituciones
democráticas
bueno
en argentina se le celebró más o menos
los 20 años de la gran crisis del 2012
de esta crisis salieron las dos fuerzas
políticas que gobernaron el país durante
los últimos 20 años
y ahora hay mucha gente que se pregunta
pero
los resultados en términos económicos de
los dos el enfrentamiento permanente
entre los dos fuerzas dejan el país con
muchas palabras con muchas preguntas
calor
como
evolucionar como encontrar una u otra
fuerza política que va a suceder mejor
en términos económicos y que va a mover
el país en una otra
en nuestra época política
pero esto quede mucho en el aire
y hay un pesimismo me parece que con la
política creo que la juventud y muchos
otros sectores están cansados de los
políticos votan por el menos el menos
mal o
mejor conocido o por una aventura pero
el fondo de todo eso me parece que es
muy pesimista que la que la política no
va a cambiar las realidades económicas y
no va no va a dar un futuro
con mucha
esperanza para la gente pero al mismo
tiempo es peligroso un desarraigo tan
fuerte sobre todo de la juventud la
política tiene que tener cierta
confianza en cuanto a lo que es el
funcionamiento democrático no vamos a
preguntarle ya es la musa precisamente
por esta cuestión porque claro cómo
piensan renovarse quizás a la cuestión
los partidos tradicionales en chile de
cara a tener un rol en el futuro que
ahora han perdido ya es na los demás
partidos que no van a ser parte de este
gobierno tendrán el desafío entonces de
actualizarse actualizar su liderazgo
también creo que hay en términos de
liderazgos comienzan quedado bastante
atrás
y parte de esto por ejemplo es ser una
oposición activa pero una oposición que
de alguna manera construya que sea un
aporte hace poco ocurrió como anécdota
y un episodio en que la presidenta del
senado que es representante es parte de
la democracia cristiana un partido que
en algún momento fue muy fuerte en chile
y es para mí uno de los reflejos más
grandes de como estos partidos
tradicionales han ido perdiendo terreno
hoy en la conversión porque
constitucional tienen sólo a un
representante lo que fue una sorpresa
y esta senadora dijo en el congreso dejó
su micrófono abierto sin darse cuenta
y comentó riéndose que ella veía que iba
a ser muy difícil para el próximo
gobierno lo que se les venía y que lleva
a tomar palco no como diciendo puede
observar y ríen en medio de risas yo
creo que ese tipo de vieja política la
ciudadanía ya le parece
lejana la ciudadanía espera otras cosas
incluso si se plantean ser oposición
ella fue bastante crítica
por por esto por este episodio y creo
que refleja muy bien una manera de hacer
las cosas que ya no está siendo aceptada
por la ciudadanía y en donde los
votantes de manera crítica lo han
demostrado en las urnas y están
esperando algo que sea más bien desde lo
constructivo y no desde esta vieja
manera de saber es posible en una tarea
el reto de que la vieja política se
reactualizó a estas circunstancias de
que vivimos actualmente y en esta época
que se abre de la pandemia muchísimas
gracias a los tres ha sido un placer me
quedo ya sin tiempo gratis gracias
patrick weil david warner mi compañera
ya es una musa desde chile y a todos
ustedes hasta la próxima semana quien en
primera plana gracias